welcome back to here and now and part
two of our story about the business
relationship that's forming between this
province and Greenland it's based on the
promise in Greenland's growing offshore
oil industry companies here see
opportunity but in Greenland and in
Denmark that economic promise is tinged
with concern about the environment here
again is Murray one Copenhagen the
capital of Denmark a city with three
times the population of Newfoundland and
Labrador Greenland has been a colony of
Denmark for several centuries in 2009
Greenland got self-rule but it doesn't
have economic independence Denmark pays
half a billion dollars a year in
subsidies to its former colony some
Danes want Greenland to hit it big with
oil so the subsidy won't be needed
anymore it's going to be good for
Denmark economy if they find anything
they could skin it up enough money so
they can get free from
and being
our country I think perhaps it'd be good
for them if they get there they are
going to be independent yes there are
others here however who think the price
of Greenland's independence might be too
high for the environment I think no good
idea i think is to leave it where is why
because of the environment and all
enough on the market thing it's very
important that you take care of the
nature there so it is very special we
think that we can do it better bacala
cling is head of the inner wit
circumpolar Council it represents any
weight around the world he prefers a
go-slow approach to development because
the small population of Greenland has
enough challenges already we have all
experienced the harshest sir adaptation
to modern life that any people in the
world could have gone through and we
have barely survived
intimate leaders are meeting this week
in Ottawa to talk about how best to
manage natural resources in the Arctic a
business delegation from that country
will be in Newfoundland and Labrador
this week to see what we have to offer
Sean Skinner invited them there some of
the business will do on the Rome they
don't need government some of this is
going to be driven by a business
necessity but they are going to have to
be infrastructure and social plans put
in place by the government to Greenland
and the government to new flame Labrador
ibly to be able to service what's going
to happen in Greenland Jeff Howard
thinks Greenland's boom could come at a
good time for this province in time to
replace jobs drying up in our offshore
oil industry and in Fort McMurray you
know there was a mining activity going
up as an iron ore mine being built there
there's the aluminium smelter
potentially that might happen there you
know rare earth elements you know you
know new Philander's could be with the
direct air links new Flanders could be
supplying a lot of people up there the
minister of transportation for Greenland
is also in the province this week and
he's not just looking at airports he'll
be looking at st. John's harbour the
port here is a lot closer to Greenland
than any offshore service based in
Europe so the minister and the air
greenland officials can be sure of one
thing while they're in the province and
that is that they'll get a very warm
welcome for here and now i'm marie wad'n
and say johns if you want to dig a
little deeper into the greenland story
simply go online to cbc.ca / NL and of
course if you've got any thoughts on the
greenland story contact us at here and
now dot NL at CBC CA or give us a call
the number is 1 800 5639 332 in the st.
John's area 5 7 6 5 110
you